depuis deux ans les compagnies
d'assurance qui couvre le monde agricole
ont décidé de faire le ménage certains
modèles d'affaires qui était autrefois
acceptable ne trouve plus grâce à leurs
yeux
et certaines pratiques pourtant répandue
dans le milieu passe moins bien un dur
coup pour les agriculteurs qui peine à
s'adapter à ces nouvelles réalités
je comprends pas comment j'ai pu passer
du bon temps hier pas celui qui m
importe l'âge je le comprends pas tout
je me dis ça va se placer au moins donné
il va arriver quelque chose quelqu'un va
servir sa peau de bruxelles au cours des
dernières années
certains producteurs agricoles sont
passés de héros à zéro auprès de leur
assureur
les compagnies trouvent que la
récréation a assez duré et qu'il est
temps de faire le ménage
donc il faut juste que ce soit un
appariement entre le risque la perte et
la prime et c'est aussi simple que ça et
rien d'autre que c'est très décourageant
de bonnes discussions avec ces gens à
l'eau leurs excuses je les trouve très
facile
[Musique]
samuel bouchard doit composer avec la
nouvelle réalité du monde des assurances
depuis un an
le producteur laitier vite avec une épée
de damoclès au-dessus de la tête
en fait tout ce qui est le bon outil
mais son contenu les animaux j'ai plus
aucune protection le fait que 6 1 6
je parle tout bleu
la firme c'est ce qui nous fait rire
fixées ci à disparaît mais nous jusqu'en
les relations sont au beau fixe entre le
producteur laitier et sa compagnie
d'assurance cette année-là il obtient un
rabais de 10% pour son dossier
exemplaire aux sinistrés prévention
[Musique]
en 2019 il agrandit son étable pour
donner plus d'espacé aux vaches les
travaux qui sont aujourd'hui presque
achevés sont effectués en famille mais
nous on avait toujours été fait ça de
cette façon là par le passé aussi mon
père avait un courant en construction et
charpentiers menuisiers
donc on avait quand même un bon
background pour ça on n'avait pas vu la
nécessité d'engager une entrepreneure
parce que dans l'agriculture il ya
beaucoup de projet d'autoconstruction
ces pauvres pour le premier à faire ça
c'est très très court elle met son
assureur de toujours promutuel lui
demande d' embaucher un entrepreneur
général
depuis deux ans les exigences des
assureurs envers le milieu agricole ont
changé c'est que le contexte lui aussi
est différent
le nombre de réclamations pis l'ampleur
des réclamations sont à la hausse de
façon importante
puis ça vient principalement de deux
types de pertes le c'est soit des
incendies
[Musique]
qui sont souvent d'origine électrique où
on parle d'effondrement de bâtisses
masse on a eu beaucoup on en a eu
beaucoup dans les derniers hivers aussi
les fermes sont plus en plus grosse
notamment des fermes laitières donc
quand ça brûle on a beaucoup de fermes
lors qui m'a des 20 30 millions de
dollars
et donc ça prend du capital pour assurer
sa si on continuait comme ont été rendus
là-bas c'est l'ensemble des assurés de
qui payer pour les pertes pour les
pertes qui arrivait du côté de
l'assurance agricole dans le code samuel
bouchard ce qui a été déterminant dans
l'analyse de son dossier
c'est l'électricité le producteur les
types voulait faire lui même une partie
des travaux alors que depuis le début
promutuel lui demander d'engager un
maître électricien quads électriques
quand on arrive dans un milieu agricole
c'est pas simple le mexique expliquant
qu'à tokyo malheureuse mais des
installations qui sont pas toujours
conformes qui m'ont dit de phalanges
mandaté next siens le j'ai essayé de
savoir at il faut vraiment que je touche
pas car rien rien rien puis par après
belle aux riziculteurs ouvrira tussauds
à l'entrepreneur l'électricien puis bon
je dis est trop tard notre décision est
pris à rentrer comment faire un choix
qui troublent puis l'avis de non
renouvellement qui m'ont offerte à me
borie partout l'avocate de l'upu l'oms
est la seule façon d'annuler un avis non
renouvellement c'est qu'ils me briot fin
assurances
l'union des producteurs agricoles qui
croule sous les appels de détresse
depuis deux ans afin un sondage pour
savoir s'il ya réellement un problème
elle a été estomaqué d'apprendre que 6 %
ses membres sont sans assurance
comme samuel bouchard d'autres on tue
d'importantes hausses de primes
il ya quand même 20 % des répondants qui
nous ont dit que leurs hausses de primes
étaient au-delà de 14%
et quand on parle de moyenne vous avez
des extrêmes
à travers ce alors vous avez des
producteurs qui comme monsieur jeunes et
subissent des hausses absolument
déraisonnable excessive
les gens y viennent ici pas de droit
belge à la ferme je n'ai est une
institution dans la région pendant l'été
près de deux millions de personnes
envahissent les champs de l'entreprise
au menu fraises framboises pomme naïs
les citrouilles suivent à l'automne
c'est l'auto cueillette nous on appelle
ça le circuit court
on va nos produits ici alors les niches
en bien ici viennent poser quelques
belles zaira monseur fraises ou leurs
pommes
il pose quelques [ __ ] certeau qu'ils
en fabriquant des cpe qui dénie si ils
font un long trajet d'autobus
ils viennent pour dix minutes avec fu
leur faire faire des choses différentes
parce qu'un enfin au bout de 15 minutes
qu'est ce qu'on fait après au fil des
ans l'entreprise a développé un
véritable parc d'attraction à travers
les champs au début c'était des tabacs
technique puis les enfants manger puis
mais on a dix gardes déballeurs soir
puis après ça on aura ajouté plein de
choses comme le jumping pilot un jeu
gonflable
les gens font tout la tu sais ils
peuvent embarquer 25 30 enfants là
dessus c'est 30 pieds par 60 pieds il
n'ya pas aussi un million d'enfants
depuis 10 ans contre puis ils veulent
plus parce qu'il risque d'accident c'est
ce qu'ils nous disent
[Musique]
promutuel a cessé d'assurer la ferme en
je veux pas commenter un dossier
particulier mais c'est sûr qu'on va
regarder un peu l'ampleur de ses
activités l'autre effectivement on
devient peut-être un peu plus un peu
plus frileuses si on veut c'est quand il
ya des risques de blessures corporelles
adopter des activités qui vont mettre en
jeu la sécurité ou la santé des
visiteurs sur sur la ferme jamais il est
arrivé un accident
le jumping pelo et jamais rien arrivé
quoi qu'il en soit la ferme jeune et a
dû se tourner vers une autre compagnie
d'assurance qui a exigé le démantèlement
du jumping pelo et augmenter sa prime
d'assurance de 7200 dollars elle est
passée à 80,18 1000 $ par année
c'est 13 fois la prime avec un dj team
de 25000 dollars
ça veut dire qu'il y aura jamais une
réclamation
ces 8000 $ par mois pensez-y 8000 $
c'est ça tu viens tout défaire le budget
là je ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'on va
faire si ça ne se règle le port jeu
qu'on va enlever les jeux on va enlever
tout ce qui est plastique est ce que
c'est parce a bien changé les justes
elles tout de la ferme
je suis pas le seul à vivre selon ce
témoin les regardent je ne plaiderai
même poloz je vivrai avec hiller sa pop
de partout dans la province
à lui paye je pense que il ya moyen de
faire quelque chose mais ça arrive aussi
à des petites fermes en émergence les
personnes qui veulent les assurés alors
pas d'assurance qu'aucun pouvoir vendre
pourquoi que un autre serait assuré que
nous on serait pas assurée on se pose la
question
[Musique]
alexandre guérin exploite une toute
petite entreprise nouveau genre c'est un
peu le un aménagement paysager tout est
comme scb là dedans donc j'ai des
petites forêts nourricière mais ça
permet de faire des kayaks tu sois de
champignons de tisanes des pièces de
légumes à racines
on a aussi des noirs du québec c'est
tout cueillies à la main aussi ses
relations avec les assureurs sont
compliquées ça fait environ 3 ac et
j'essaie d'avoir des assureurs et la
réponse des assureurs c'était dans le
fond on peut pour vous assurer de passe
que vous n'êtes pas seuls et depuis le
jour 1
en coulisses on nous explique que si le
client n'a pas assuré son entreprise dès
le départ
cela démontre un manque de sérieux
alexandre guérin voit les choses
autrement
j'étends démarrage savais même pas si
mon entreprise allait fonctionner au
début puis la pression quand j'ai vu que
mon entreprise
ah oui en vélo oui peut-être que je vais
en vif puis je vais continuer là dedans
c'est lorsque j'ai commencé à vouloir
m'assurer présentement je suis dans un
espace temps gouacide de poids est
assurée moi j'essaie de paume et enfin
parce que la vie continue
ccc 5 comme ça mais c'est ce trait 5 lui
paiera quand est de convaincre les
assureurs du québec de se partager le
risque est de reprendre les laissés pour
compte
ce qu'on s'aperçoit c'est la meilleure
façon peut-être d'adresser les problèmes
c'est que un groupe d'assureurs accepte
d'embarquer dans un programme et se
répartissent les coûts les risques et
donc nécessairement les indemnités qui
arrive lorsque des sinistres dans le
domaine de l'assurance
[Musique]
on a eu des discussions avec l'ue péaule
pays bas les primes doivent être quand
même conséquente avec avec les risques
et avec les réclamations qu'on a
il ya pas de magie en assurant cela si
nous avons des subventions pour appeler
votre député n'y ait pas de compagne sur
un an
devant l'impasse lupe à tente maintenant
de recruter d'autres assureurs à
l'étranger pour mettre sur pied un
programme d'assurance alternatifs vont
nous trouver une compagnie altruiste qui
veut perdre de l'argent
je leur souhaite bonne chance autant au
québec à l'international un nouveau défi
pour le monde agricole